america is lending this effort together
with our allies and partners providing
enormous levels of security and
humanitarian assistance that we're
adding to today and we're going to
continue to do more in the days and
weeks ahead
we're crippling putin's economy with
punishing sanctions
that's going to only grow more painful
over time with the entire
nato and eu behind us and many other
countries
what's at stake here for the principles
that the united states and the united
nations and across the world stand for
it's about freedom
it's about the right of people to
determine their own future
it's about making sure ukraine never
will never be a victory for putin no
matter what advances he makes on the
battlefield
the american people are answering
president zielinski's call
for more help more weapons for ukraine
to defend us of more tools to fight
russian aggression
and that's what we're doing
in fact we started our assistance
ukraine before this war began
as they started to do exercises along
the ukrainian border the russians
started in march of last year
we took the threat of putin invading
very seriously
we acted on it we sent ukraine more
security assistance last year 650
million dollars in weapons including
anti-air and anti-armor equipment before
the invasion
more than we had ever provided before
so when the invasion began they already
had in their hands the kinds of weapons
that needed to counter russian advances
and once the war started we immediately
rushed 350 million in additional aid to
further address their needs
hundreds of anti-air systems thousands
of anti-tank weapons
transport helicopters
arm patrol boats
and other high mobility vehicles radar
systems that help track incoming
artillery and unmanned drones
secure communications equipment and
tactical gear
satellite imagery and and
analysis capacity
and it's clearly helped ukraine inflict
dramatic losses on russian forces
on saturday
my administration authorized another 200
million dollars to keep a steady flow of
weapons and ammunition moving to ukraine
now i'm once again
using my presidential authority to
actively
activate an additional security
assistance to continue to help ukraine
fend off russia's assault
an additional 800 million dollars in
assistance
that brings the total of new u.s
security assistance to ukraine to 1
billion
just this week
these are the large these are direct
transfers of equipment from our
department of defense to the ukrainian
military to help them as they fight
against this invasion
and i thank the congress for
appropriating these funds
this new package on its own is going to
provide unprecedented assistance to
ukraine
it includes 800 anti-aircraft systems
to make sure the ukrainian military can
continue to can continue to stop the
planes and helicopters that have been
attacking their people and to defend
their ukrainian airspace
and at the request of president
zielinski we have identified
and are helping ukraine acquire
additional
longer-range anti-aircraft systems and
the munitions for those systems
our new assistance package
also includes 9 000 anti-armor systems
these are portable high
high accurate high accurately high
accuracy shoulder mounted missiles that
the ukrainian forces have been using
with great effect to destroy invading
tanks and armored vehicles
it'll include 7 000 small arms machine
guns shotguns grenade launchers to equip
the ukrainians including the brave women
and men who are defending their cities
as civilians and they're on the
countryside as well and we're and we and
as well as the ammunition artillery and
mortar rounds to go with small arms 20
million rounds in total 20 million
rounds
this will include drones which
which uh demonstrates our commitment to
sending our most cutting-edge systems to
ukraine for its defense
and we're not doing this alone
our allies and partners have stepped up
to provide significant shipments of
security assistance and will continue to
help facilitate these deliveries as well
the united states and our allies and
partners are fully committed to surging
weapons of assistance to the ukrainians
and more will be coming
as we source additional stocks of
equipment that are all that we're ready
to transfer
now now i want to be honest with you
this could be a long and difficult
battle
but the american people will be
steadfast in our support of the people
of ukraine in the face of putin's
immoral unethical attacks on civilian
populations
we are united in our abhorrence of
putin's depraved onslaught
we're going to continue to have their
backs as they fight for their freedom
their democracy their very survival
we're going to give ukraine
the arms to fight and defend themselves
through all the difficult days ahead
we're going to continue to mobilize
humanitarian relief to support people
within ukraine and those who've been
forced to flee ukraine
in just the past few weeks we provided
300 million humanitarian assistance to
the people in ukraine and in neighboring
countries
tens of thousands of tons of food water
medicine and other basic supplies to
support the people in need
our experts on the ground in poland and
moldova
and other neighboring countries
are there to make real-time assessments
of the rapidly evolving crisis to get
urgently needed humanitarian supplies to
the people in need when they need it
and we will support ukraine's economy
with direct financial assistance as well
and together with our allies and
partners
we will keep up the pressure on putin's
crumbling economy
isolating him on the global stage
that's our goal
may putin paid the price weaken his
position while strengthening the hand of
the ukrainians on the battlefield and
the negotiating team
together with our allies and partners
we're going to stay the course
we'll do everything we can to push for
and end this tragic unnecessary war
this is a struggle to pitch the
appetites of an autocrat
against humankind's desire to be free
and let there be no doubt no uncertainty
no question
america stands with the forces of
freedom
we always have we always will
i thank you all and god bless you and
i'm going to walk over and sign this
legislative sign this bill to allow the
drawdown of those materials
and make god protect their
young ukrainians are out there defending
their country
what i'm signing here
is
the delegation authority under section
50631
the foreign assistance act 1961. thanks
very much
mr president what will it take for you
to send the polish that president
[Applause]
quickly for the next event
cameras just need to present